if if there's one thing that I've done
that I'm like the proudest of of
everything all right is the fact that um
people talk about wow you've had such
success and it's just been so overnight
and whatever well whatever success I've
got has come after like eight years of
just nothing working out as trying to
get a job what was your first job you
got actually I had some really seedy
jobs for a little kid the first two jobs
I got actually totally had to do with
like the porno industry until eventually
like around age 22 I got a job at a
place called video archives what was
funny about that job was the fact that
like people said oh so that's kind of
like your film school yeah well what
what that store was more or less it's
not a film school it was kind of a it
was a closer equivalent would be it was
like my Village Voice yeah and I got to
be Jay hoberman I got to be Andrew
Sarris of the store you know be like the
little Mr critic you know at the store
putting films in people's hands and and
arguing my points why this movie was
good or why that movie was bad and
everything